This simple example shows some key parts of an XML-formatted FHIR patient resource.
Local information such as its last update and its local resource ID,
an HTML presentation of the key information for human consumption,
or if the receiving system is not able to interpret the structured information,
any local extensions to the standard,
the standard-defined structured data content.
Here is an example of a JSON-formatted FHIR allergy intolerance resource.
The highlighted area contains the text for display for reasons we just discussed.
Here, I had removed that text so we can more easily focus on the structured information.
It begins by showing that this allergy problem is clinically active but is unconfirmed.
Patients often report allergies,
but that does not mean they experienced
an actual allergy as opposed to a medication side effect.
This allergy is for penicillin,
and according to the Mayo Clinic,
research has shown that penicillin allergies may be over-diagnosed,
and that patients may report a penicillin allergy that has never been confirmed.
A misdiagnosed penicillin allergy may result in the use of
less appropriate or more expensive and possibly more dangerous antibiotics.
Here, you see that this allergy is in the medication category.
Medication is one of four allowed values for an allergy intolerance category.
Here you see the entire value set,
the list of allowed values for this data element
taken from the relevant page on the HL7 FHIR site.
Food, environmental, and biologic allergies such as to
an X-ray contrast agent or a vaccination can also be documented using this resource.
Knowing that it is a medication allergy could be helpful to
software so that it knows to check on it when prescribing new medications.
Here you see a reference to an RxNorm code or RxCUI
7980 which is for penicillin G. Actually,
penicillin is a group of antibiotics and this is only one part of the penicillin group.
Patients allergic to one member of the group
are usually presumed to be allergic to the entire group.
So I think the RxCUI of 70618 might have been a better choice.
I'll leave it to you to verify that and find out what
this RxCUI is for with the RxNorm tool you used earlier.
Here, you see that the allergy manifests itself as hives,
an outbreak of swollen,
pale red bumps or plaques or wheals on the skin.
This should be the SNOMED CT code for hives.
I leave it to you to verify that with the browser you used earlier.
These references to RxNorm and SNOMED CT
illustrate an important characteristic of FHIR we mentioned earlier.
It builds upon existing standards via
terminology bindings that specify these relationships.
Here, you see all the terminology bindings for this one resource.
I provide a link to a page from the FHIR site listing
all the terminology bindings used in the standard.
Here is a simple example to show how FHIR
also rests on key elements from earlier HL7 standards.
As you see here at the top,
the marital status value set comes from HL7 v3.
If you go to the detailed description tab on the patient resource page on the FHIR site,
you will find this section for marital status.
Click here on the marital status codes link and you will get to the same table.